-Benedict, you are starring in
"The Grinch".
And as the Grinch,
it's your job
to always look
grumpy and annoyed.
-Yes.
-Take a look at this camera here
and give us your best Grinch.
Side by side. Yeah.
Two.
Yeah!
-That's a good --
That's a good Grinch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, I thought I would put
your Grinch to the test
by taking you on the
"Try Not to Laugh" challenge.
We're gonna take turns
watching funny videos.
And you have to keep
your best Grinch face...
-Okay.
-...while trying not to laugh.
-My Grinch resting face.
Here it comes.
-You can go first, actually.
So...
-Okay, yeah.
-I'm psyched 'cause I can laugh.
Okay. Benedict, you go first.
Ready?
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Watch that monitor. Let's play
the first video there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Speaks indistinctly ]
-All right, here we go.
My turn.
-All right, good luck.
Good luck to you.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
What? I don't understand
what I just saw.
Wait, what did I just see?
I have no idea what's happening.
Was that ice?
-That was ice.
That was someone trying
to get to their car.
[ Laughter ]
-He got hit by the other car?
Oh, my gosh.
-Not what you think
is gonna happen.
-Why would I laugh at that?
No, no, no.
All right, so far
we're zero for zero.
Okay, it's your turn.
-All right.
Whew.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
He did it! Oh, my God!
Look at that.
He did it!
That's -- That's good.
Tunnel vision. Tunnel vision.
-All right.
All right, here we go.
-English classical...training.
-My turn. Here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
No training at all.
-Straight off the streets.
Go on, do it, Jimmy.
-Yep.
[ Farting noise ]
[ Laughter ]
-You had a much, much
tougher challenge.
That was so
straight out of the gate.
I had no idea.
Ready? [ Fart noise ] No.
I wasn't ready.
He certainly wasn't ready.
-Wait, what?
Can we see that one again?
[ Fart noise ]
[ Laughter ]
Uhhh. [ Laughing ]
-So sorry.
Whoever that is, I'm so sorry.
So sorry.
Age is not kind.
Oh, God.
-[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Oh, God.
This is the final round.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God. Is it my turn
or your turn?
It's my turn.
[ Laughter ]
-We can watch --
[ Laughing ]
We can watch the video
at the same time.
-I don't think I can stop it.
Okay.
-Okay. Here we go.
Not laughing.
-Grinch. Okay, come on.
-Here we go.
-[ Blows raspberry ]
All right, here we go.
-Go.
[ All chanting "We want Santa" ]
-Where is he?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Oh, my God!
[ Blows raspberry ]
Dave, can we watch that --
that football --
-Wow.
-Can we watch the football one
one more time?
The football one?
-The football one.
[ Fart noise ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Benedict Cumberbatch!
Stick around -- [ Laughing ]
We'll be right back for more
on "The Tonight Show"!